cette réforme est particulièrement
nécessaire pour la filière police
judiciaire confrontée à de grandes
difficultés
les causes de la crise que connaît cette
filière sont multiples dû notamment à
une complexification excessive et
toujours plus grande de la procédure
pénale et une politique des ressources
humaines peu adaptée aux spécificités de
ces métiers cause que nous avons
identifié en 2020 dans le cadre d'une
initiative de la direction générale de
la police nationale rassemblant tous les
services autour d'une coordination
nationale de l'investigation
un certain nombre de ces facteurs à
contribué à ce que la filière
investigation de la police nationale
soit malheureusement moins efficace
qu'elle n'a plus l'être dans le passé
sur la période sur la période 2010-2019
je ne prends pas en considération de
l'année 2020 qui est singulière en
raison de la crise sanitaire le volume
global de la délinquance traité par les
services de police à varier assez peu
avec une moyenne de 2,4 millions de fait
enregistrés par an
il convient de souligner que la
direction centrale de la sécurité
publique traite l'essentiel de la
délinquance enregistrée par la police
nationale y compris pour les faits
relevant de la criminalité organisée
59% de l'agrégat de la grande
criminalité pour la DCSP contre
seulement 8% pour la DCPJ et 29% pour la
préfecture de police
toujours sur la période de 2010-2019 les
taux d'élucination ont baissé de manière
constante et significatives quelle que
soit l'agrégat concerné atteinte au bien
à tête aux personnes ou délinquance
économiques et financière
moins 12 points pour les violences non
crapuleuses - 15 points pour les
violences sexuelles
- 2 points pour les atteintes au bien
qui sont déjà très faiblement élucidés -
16 points pour les infractions
économiques et financières
cette évolution n'est donc pas la
conséquence d'une augmentation du volume
des faits à traiter
la baisse de la performance globale de
la filière contribue aussi en partie à
la constitution de stocks de procédures
dans les services généralistes au mois
de juin 2022 le nombre total des
procédures merci monsieur le Président
le nombre total des procédures en
portefeuille pour les services de la
direction centrale de la sécurité
publique c'est levé à plus d'un million
500 000 soit une moyenne de 104
procédures par enquêteurs avec de fortes
disparités selon les départements
par ailleurs j'entends certains
magistrats dire publiquement que la
qualité des procédures est en baisse et
exprimer le constat d'un retrait de
l'encadrement officier commissaire dans
la conduite des en-têtes il est vrai que
les policiers du corps d'encadrement et
d'applications qui constituent
aujourd'hui l'ossature de la filière
investigation des services de la
sécurité publique ne sont pas assez
formés et insuffisamment encadré
[Musique]